uh take me back bro cause
I feel like uh in retrospect what I
loved about
J Cole right you and him have this sit
down y'all have this conversation which
at the time was so it was crazy to
people unexpected yeah because you had
said [ __ ] J Cole it felt like some of
his album was kind of geared towards
your generation at least if not
specifically to you
um and then you guys have this sit-down
conversation yeah that caught Everybody
by surprise
um how like talk about that convo and
just like did you actually take anything
from it or or do you feel like you're
taking things from it now
after
what do we take from I'm saying like you
know obviously it was a it was an
insightful conversation I feel like J
Cole was trying to give some real game
and like you know trying to understand
the younger generation yeah he was
trying to understand a Young Generation
he because
at that time you know like he people
didn't understand what was going on
right music
but they're just like there's no wave
coming in we don't understand it but
we're just gonna roll with it and he's
trying to understand what was going on
do y'all [ __ ] with J Cole yeah there's I
don't have no problems with him do you
feel like he predicted kind of like what
ended up happening with your rap career
nope because I'm still here I got I'm
not saying that you're I'm not saying
that you're not like still [ __ ] rich
and successful I just mean in terms of
like you know
I feel like
there's so many parts of that
era of rap where like people got famed
so fast they were so young you know what
I'm saying like
and I feel like that was some of the
foresight that he was saying not even
necessarily about quote unquote falling
off you know what I mean
you don't think you don't think he
predicted anything
I don't think pretty [ __ ] no that's fair
I'm still here I mean you're still here
100